ces grillages c'était peut-être la
dernière fois que jacques delisle les
voyait l'ex-juge a quitté le pénitencier
de la macaza dans les laurentides en
milieu d'après-midi quelques heures plus
tôt il assistait par visioconférence à
son audience pour remise en liberté qui
lui a été accordée en moins de 15
minutes au palais de justice de québec
son avocat est satisfait mais guère
surpris comment aurait-on pu logiquement
de maintenir en détention après neuf
entreprises autorisent au mans et alors
qu'il est âgé de 10 ans plus donc moins
dangereux moins susceptibles de prendre
la fuite
plus tôt cette semaine le ministre
fédéral de la justice a ordonné la tenue
d'un nouveau procès parce que jacques
delisle aurait été victime d'une erreur
judiciaire lorsqu'il a été reconnu
coupable du meurtre de sa femme en 2012
mais ce retour à la case départ ne
signifie pas que jacques delisle est
innocent rappelle le directeur des
poursuites criminelles et pénales
les parties sont donc replacer dans le
même état qu'il était lors de la mise en
accusation initiale de jacques delisle
en juin 2010 en conséquence les
procédures judiciaires reprennent quant
à l'accusation de meurtre au premier
degré en attendant son nouveau procès
jacques delisle devra résider à son
domicile de québec
il ne pourra pas quitter le canada
tentait d'obtenir un passeport posséder
une arme ou communiquez avec certaines
personnes
mais la suite est incertaine puisque ses
avocats espèrent carrément faire tomber
l'accusation de meurtre et éviter un
nouveau procès maintenant est-ce que
nous allons réussir julie nioche and
cable m l'acquéreur est convaincu que
les nouvelles preuves médico légales de
la défense démontre que la femme de
jacques delisle s'est suicidé mais des
aveux faits par jacques dolle la radio
canada en 2015 pourrait-il mener à des
accusations différentes y avait admis
avoir aidé
madame mettant une arme à feu près un
proche d'elle pensant à la prendre une
marche et c'est ce qui pourrait accuser
de complicité ou des citations chefs
d'accusation qui pourraient être portées
on verra le futur 2 0 la fille de
jacques delisle
qui nous a accordé une entrevue plus tôt
cette semaine s'est dit ému par la
libération de son père le dossier doit
revenir en cour en septembre prochain
ici alexandre duval radio canada québec